[Musique]
alors les paparazzades gros gros gros
dossier qui à jet et paparazzi ici oui
toi ça intéresse personne et vous vous
êtes pas connu alors à qui a paradé
évidemment vous le dernier gros coup
c'est quoi sébastien pour toi celui dont
je peux parler vraiment gros c'était
aulas on a prayer la livrée sans oui on
alimente les magazines de nos amis à peu
près toutes les semaines donc toutes les
semaines il ya des histoires argile
autre question d'argent
alors ce qui rapporte le plus d'argent à
la limite si on les laisse coupe
étrangers c'est-à-dire que quand on fait
une personnalité qui est connu dans le
monde entier si c'est une grosse
histoire on va le vendre une grosse
somme à quatre cinq six pays donc c'est
pas automatiquement les scoops les plus
connus mais si on fait le mari d'une
princesse avec sa maîtresse et ses
landes
ça rapporte combien peu près ce que vous
dites là mais ça c'est plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros par pays
donc on peut arriver à une grosse somme
d'accord donc vous la plus grosse somme
cause est touchée en plein contrôle
[Rires]
quasi people la députée regardez voilà à
quoi ressemble le quotidien de la
princesse pics dans les rues de lantin à
l'epa paradis pour les stars c'est un
peu comme les mouches pour les chevaux
un enfer pas un passant des dizaines de
photographes 24 heures sur 24 en bas de
chez elle comme à des milliers de
kilomètres de là dans le sud de la
france pour son voyage de noces avec le
prince william
cette hâte en 2012 un voyage qui aurait
dû rester secret mais c'est sans compter
avec ces images prises au téléobjectif
et désolé vous n'allez pas voir grand
chose qu on y voit la princesse seins
nus des images publiées en france par le
journal closer et qui ont immédiatement
fait le tour du monde
à l'époque le journal s'arrache mais
avant-hier closer a été condamné à la
peine maximale
la note est salée le journal devra
débourser 140 5000 euros avec de tels
risques financiers le métier de
paparazzi à l'ancienne est il menacé
nous avons posé la question au célèbre
paparazzi pascal rostain pour qui le
business semble continuer tranquillement
à la terrasse d'un café parisien
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes sur un coup en ce
moment ouais mais alors je peux pas vous
expliquer sur quoi je suis c'est vrai
que ce qui nous intéresse en ce moment
c'est pas de thune à charbonnat là c'est
aussi les politiques mais alors le
métier de paparazzi les en danger ou pas
dans le métier des pâtes à mener c'est
jusque là justice en france est très
très sévère et ça prouve que les stars
françaises n'ont pas de souci à se faire
par contre que la presse française qui
va de plus en plus mal à elle beaucoup
de soucis à se faire alors pour éviter
de se faire condamner la presse people
aurait trouvé la solution avec des
fausses paparazzades ou si vous préférez
des photos bidonné pour quelques
centaines d'euros
souvenez-vous en 2012 on vous avait
vendu l'amour entre nelly de la belle et
ses princes et florian en 2013 c'était
leïla et soan qui s'aimaient fort très
fort
mais malheureusement tout est faux
emilie nef naf confirme on fait toujours
des couvertures à angers sinon on fait
comment pour gagner de l'argent et de la
télé réalité à la famille royale
d'angleterre il n'y a qu'un pas le père
de megan l'autre princesse anglaise y
est allé aussi de son petit bidonnage
genre je ne suis pas invitée au mariage
bagagerie elle est quand même mesure
chez le tailleur pour le costume et
révision express de l'histoire
britannique
résultat grosse vente et grosse panique
à buckingham
alors ce sont les stars qui nous
manipulent les jours alors voyez dans
l'or devrait pas l'amener tout y est
c'est bien qu'ils sébastien qu'ils aient
en bas ça c'est moi ça c'est du concret
est ce que oui ou non vous avez déjà
organisé des fausses paparazzades c'est
à dire en accord avec le people et le
paparazzi pour que la photo sur un peu
rebelle et qu'on raconte une histoire
pour être dans la lumière est ce que oui
ou non vous ai déjà fait c'est arrivé
c'est pas courant mais oui oui c'est
arrière ou époque
ça m'a poussé à avoir un nom allait
honnêtement non ben non là c'est passé
dans le magnéto c'était soan par exemple
avec il arrête plus voilà je les avais
croisé à la sortie de l'hôtel parce que
je tenais toujours devant l'hôtel parce
qu'il sortait il allait faire des trucs
donc temps en temps je les faisais en
vraie planque dans un torrent fausses et
là c'était c'était celle qu'ils ont du
verbe mais voilà ils m'ont dit si tu
veux si tu es un peu d'argent pour nous
on va les cendres concret vous leur
donnez du cash la lah pour le oui et
voilà et donc les photos sont sortis et
une semaine après il a été en parler
partout donc il paraît que je peux le
dire pour vous avez fait loi n'a à
l'époque
en fait c'est arrivé si c'est arrivé et
pour des gros secouer tout ça et mais
j'ai fait aussi en vrai donc que ce
communiqué sont comme vous le faites
est-ce que les magazines qui vous les
achète dans merial ou lui qu est ce qu
ils le savent où est ce que vous leur
dites que c'est justement c'est là où ça
dépend ça dépendra enfin bon je pense
qu'il ya des séries c'est un trio à la
merci la voir on vient juste d'en nommer
comme ça c'est d'abord parce que souvent
quand on faisait alors on faisait des
fausses blondes franchement on en a fait
il ya 15 ans ouais on la star ac en ça
marchait très bien ce cadre story la du
temps de castel dit quand ça cartonnait
plein où tous les gens qui sortaient les
annoncer leur mariage annoncé leur
séparation il apporte ses chances un
taux trois mois après
une fausse couche ouais ça allait tout
le temps avec en plus il y avait à côté
feuilletonnant il racontait n'importe
quoi on devrait dire ils vendent et des
photos alors dans les normes et les
indiens et c'était et yahvé n'importe
quoi ouais et on savait plus ou moins à
ce qu'était un peu pénible d'ailleurs on
devait les payer et donc faire payer des
paparazzi mais on l'aimé il y avait une
part qui partait pour la star
directement
donc on négocie directement avec les
stars combien tu veux ma chasse était et
il faisait monter les enchères
c'est du coup dernier pas de procès
derrière c'est derrière mais ce qui
était très inattendu c'est que quand on
faisait par exemple je suis enceinte
dans closer et que de quinze jours après
salaires publics aidés et fait une
fausse couche et quinze jours après les
troupes pour dire en fait j'ai menti aux
deux familles ridicule sa musique ça
c'était le défi de si grosses stars à
l'époque romane existe ça reste vous
avez eu adjani et machin ou non voilà
starsky non non non non non trois des
trois dernières questions pour conclure
dès ce que tu as fait des photos paradis
hadwin on est sous nos yeux à histoires
exemple non mais t'as pas fait de rendez
vous est venue faire la tournée comment
est-ce que tu approprié c'est vrai les
briques
oui pour sa part jennifer fait c'est
combien tu as des montants que je crois
on m'avait proposé 50 mille balles à
l'époque mais j'ai dit oui voilà c'est
fait reposer beaucoup beaucoup oui par
genre les autres époques ne puisse aller
tous les jours nous était beaucoup plus
que ce que je veux avec magali perdre à
qui les connaît bien là pour le coup les
gens de coeur elle est aujourd'hui ils
en font plus mais j'ai la première qui a
dénoncé ce système c'est emilie nef naf
donc à dénoncer ça en 2010 sur tellement
vrai désolé messieurs sur sa appelé
effectivement elle m'a balancé les
tarifs
donc l on lui ai proposé 50 de 1000
euros pour faire une série de trois
paparazzade donc la première c'était je
suis en couple avec mon copain tout se
passe bien
la deuxième dont ça devait sortir 15
jours après je viens de tromper mon
copain et un troisième qui produit 50 de
1000 euros le paquet moi je sais que ça
rapporte 500c sera le mot de la fin au
jeu